el pentágono pr y ce se refleja a través
de la línea de x que se muestra a
continuación dibuja la imagen de esta
reflexión utilizando la gráfica
interactiva bueno tenemos que esta es la
gráfica interactiva y esos son los
vértices pr y c
de esta figura y esta es nuestra línea
de reflexión que está en morada
esta tiene una pendiente 1 positivo ya
que es igual a equis y cuando x cambia
cierta cantidad lleva a cambiar la misma
cantidad si x cambia uno también
cambiará y en uno
nos piden dibujar la imagen de esta
reflexión utilizando la gráfica
interactiva yo aquí puedo dibujar o
poner vértices para formar la figura
reflejo y bueno los puedo poner así que
esté en donde yo quiera aunque creo que
lo estoy haciendo un reflejo muy bueno
de esta figura
pero bueno nos piden hacer la figura
reflejo y para eso tengo que conocer los
puntos exactos de estos vértices no
donde yo quiera ponerlos y para calcular
los vértices de manera exacta copie esta
imagen en mi herramienta de dibujo para
poder hacer los cálculos exactos vamos a
ver lo primero que vemos es que si
queremos reflejar cierto vértice no sé
por ejemplo este punto de aquí el p
tenemos que dibujar una línea
perpendicular a la línea de reflexión y
que contenga este punto recordemos que
esta línea morada nuestra línea de
reflexión tiene una pendiente igual a un
1 y recordamos que la fórmula de esta
recta es igual a x vamos a dibujar esta
línea perpendicular a la línea de
reflexión y continuó la misma distancia
del otro lado para encontrar el
correspondiente punto en la imagen
cómo voy a hacer esto bueno si esta
línea morada tiene una pendiente de 1 la
línea que sea perpendicular a ésta
tendrá una pendiente que será el
recíproco negativo de esta pendiente de
la línea de reflexión 1 entre 1 sigue
siendo 1 y ahora tomamos el negativo de
esto así que la pendiente de todo esto
debe ser menos 1
por suerte es así como lo dibujé la
pendiente menos 1 significa que lo que
cambie en x también cambiará en pero en
negativo para ir de este punto a este
punto aumente x y disminuir ye y tiene
que ser la misma distancia del punto
original a nuestra línea de reflexión la
que se tenga de la línea de reflexión al
punto reflejo si queremos llegar a este
punto después de la línea de reflexión
pues tengo que disminuir en y lo mismo
que tengo aquí arriba que es 1.5 hacia
abajo es 1.5 negativo y tengo que
moverme en x la misma cantidad pero
positiva entonces me muevo aquí punto 5
y 1 acá
ese es mi cambio en g y stem y también x
y aquí voy a tener el punto reflejo de p
y cuál es la coordenada de este punto
pues es en x tengo menos 4 y en jet
tengo menos 7 muy bien vamos a hacer lo
mismo para los otros vértices de esta
figura
vamos a tomar ahora nuestro vértice y
vamos a dibujar nuestra línea
perpendicular a partir de este punto
hacia la línea de reflexión
entonces la vamos dibujando más o menos
así y continuo para poder encontrar
después mi punto reflejo qué distancia
tuve que recorrer para llegar desde el
punto a este punto de intersección
bueno pues tuve que moverme en x 2.5
unidades a la izquierda así que me
cambio en x es negativo el cambio en x
es igual a menos 2.5
cuanto también y para ser de menos 2.5
hacia arriba es un cambio positivo así
que me cambio en que es igual a 2.5
positiva
y esto que dice aquí tengo que hacerlo
igual para llegar al punto aquí arriba
entonces me cambio en x queremos que era
menos 2.5 me muevo dos lugares dos
lugares y medio hacia la izquierda ya
estoy en x ese es mi cambio en x y para
encontrar la 'jet tengo que subir 2.5
unidades aquí tengo punto 5 1 2
este es mi cambio en y notamos que es
exactamente lo mismo que el cambio en ya
que tenía aquí abajo bueno ahora vamos a
encontrar el punto reflejo del vértice c
este es nuestro vértice vamos a dibujar
nuestra línea perpendicular de cee a
nuestra línea de reflexión más o menos
así y me sigo y veamos cuál es la
distancia o la diferencia en y en x que
tuve que recorrer para llegar a esta
intersección bueno mi diferencia en
james es de 8 a 2 y medio entonces tuve
que bajar aquí 5.5 es negativa porque
estoy yendo hacia abajo sobre el eje y
me diferencia entidad es igual a menos
5.5 y ahora cuál es mi diferencia en x
pues quiero que sea la misma distancia
pero en sentido contrario entonces si
estoy aquí en menos 3 me intersecciones
está en 2.5 tengo que moverme 5.5
lugares a la derecha me cambio en x es
positivo es igual a 5.5 y ver que creen
se me estaba olvidando escribir las
coordenadas del punto que encontramos
anteriormente este otro punto
entonces antes de seguir voy a encontrar
sus coordenadas las coordenadas de este
punto x igual a menos 2 e igual a 3 muy
bien lo que ya tenemos esto ahora vamos
a continuar con lo que estábamos
haciendo bueno ya encontré la diferencia
en x y deje de cee a la línea de
reflexión ahora tengo que moverme esta
misma distancia para encontrar su
reflejo al otro lado de la línea de
reflexión me cambian y es igual a menos
5.5 el cambio en x es de 5.5 así que me
voy a mover a la derecha para encontrar
mi x me muevo 5.5 lugares aquí va a
punto 5 1 2 3 4 5 y ahora de aquí me voy
hacia abajo 5.5 lugares punto 5 1 2 3 4
5 aquí está mi punto reflejo de ese y
voy a extender mi línea perpendicular
para que vean que este punto forma parte
de esta línea y ahora ya me queda nada
más encontrar las coordenadas de este
punto
nx tenemos a 8 y en james tenemos menos
38 menos tres ahora vamos a el siguiente
punto r
hacemos lo mismo a partir de r dibujo mi
perpendicular que tiene pendiente menos
1 con respecto a la línea de reflexión
vamos a dibujarla
así más o menos con este color verde
citó nos extendemos para poder encontrar
el otro punto reflejo
y nos queda encontrar la diferencia en x
y la diferencia en yen para ver cuál es
la distancia que tenemos que recorrer
aquí y estoy en 2 entonces de aquí la
distancia sobre y que va a ser negativa
porque estoy yendo hacia abajo es de
menos 5
me diferencia
y me diferencia en x va a ser la misma
pero con sentido contrario voy a la
derecha sobre x 5 lugares para llegar a
esta intersección así que me diferencia
en x es igual a 5 ahora para encontrar
el reflejo pues voy a ver mi diferencia
en x que es de 555 hacia la derecha aquí
y a partir de ahí bajo otros 5 y
negativo 5 lugares hacia abajo y aquí
está el reflejo de f la coordenada de
este punto es de x2 de igual a menos 8
bueno y el último punto que nos queda el
punto y vamos a dibujar nuestra
perpendicular en este color naranja
llegamos a la intersección y vamos a ver
las diferencias y la diferencia en x
para llegar a esta intersección en que
tengo que ir de 3
0 hacia abajo así que es una diferencia
negativa y esa diferencia es de -3 y a
partir de aquí la diferencia en x es de
menos 3 a 0 es una diferencia positiva
bueno ya tengo a mis distancias ahora
voy a extender la línea perpendicular
más o menos por acá y voy a aplicar la
misma diferencia en x quedamos que era 3
positivo llegó aquí a 3 y la diferencia
en estrés negativo por lo que bajó y
llegó a este punto
ese es el reflejo de iu y sus
coordenadas son 3 coma menos 3 y con
esto ya tenemos los 5 puntos necesarios
para graficar nuestro reflejo vamos a
tomar nota de las coordenadas para que
no se nos olvide al momento de escribir
la solución en nuestra sección del
ejercicio entonces tenemos que es menos
238 menos 33 coma menos 32 menos 8 y
menos 4 menos
ahora regresamos a la página y vamos a
mover los puntos para que coincidan con
los que encontramos este lo pongo en
menos 23 este otro lo voy a mover a 8
menos 3
este otro va a 3 en x menos tres en tres
- 3 este otro va a 12 x menos 8 en g y
el último va a menos cuatro coma menos 7
y con esto ya tenemos ahora sí bien
hecho el reflejo de esta figura con este
pentágono anaranjada vamos a comprobar
nuestra respuesta es correcta